- Many of my friends and other peers
are young professionals.
They earn very decent salaries,
though for a whole bunch of reasons,
some of them just don't seem
to get their finances right.
They are part of a
phenomenon that is called
high-income low net worth.
Even though they earn
very comfortable salaries,
they just don't know
how to invest properly,
they just don't know how to save,
and even though most of
them don't realize yet,
this will significantly
screw up their finances
in the long-term.
In this video, we're going to
talk about all things money
and I'm talking about
a few principales that,
in my humble opinion, are
just extremely important
for young professionals to follow.
I want to pass on some
learnings and insights
from my business education and
from the research that I did
when I started earning my first salaries
and asking myself how I
should invest the money,
what I should do with it.
Please be aware though that I am not
an investment professional
and I need to give you the disclaimer
that I am not giving investment advice.
Please do your own research
before you invest your money
in any specific product.
Hi guys, my name is Heinrich,
welcome to another coffee
break with Firm Learning.
On this channel I try to
help you become successful
in the first years of your career.
If you're taking any value
at all out of this video,
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and subscribe to this channel
to get all the regular content updates
that I'm posting for you.
I'm releasing at least one
video every single Saturday
and if you haven't followed me
yet, please also have a look
at my Instagram channel the
handle is @firmlearning.
On my Instagram I am posting
content every single day
on how you can become successful
in the first years of your career,
so have a look here as well.
In this video, we are going to
proceed in the following way.
First, I'm going to
introduce some key concepts
and metrics that I believe
you need to understand
and you need to master in order
to get your finances right.
Second, I'm going to share
with you one crucial major mistake
that I believe especially the
population of Germany is doing
with belong to their finances
and I want to help you avoid this mistake
so you can get your finances
right from the very beginning.
Third, I'm going to give you
some very actionable advice
from my experiences on what
you can do to get started
to start investing.
This will enable you to get
started without the need
of doing months and months
of research and readings.
Let's start with the first block,
and this is about metrics and concepts.
I remember that when I was
a rookie with McKinsey,
one of the partners told me in the context
of a study engagement,
you can't manage what you don't measure.
So before you really start
investing time with something,
before you really start
optimizing something,
you should establish
and define some metrics
that you will use to measure your progress
and your achievement towards
a specific goal that you have.
And I believe that this is very much true
with your personal finances as well.
You need one metric that you optimize.
And in the personal finance literature,
the metric that is most
often cited and referred
to is the metric of net worth.
Even though it simplifies
a couple of things
if you're only looking at
this one thing I do believe
that if you optimize your net worth,
if you make sure that your net worth
steadily increases over time,
this will solve pretty much
all your financial problems
for you that you will have.
So how exactly is the net worth defined?
How can you calculate
your personal net worth?
And it's much more easy than you think.
The net worth is measured
as your assets minus your liabilities.
Assets minus liabilities.
So what exactly do I mean
when I refer to assets
or liabilities in a private context?
To illustrate what
assets and liabilities mean
for the typical private
citizen, I adopted a report
from the Deutsche Bundesbank
where they show a stylized balance sheet
of a private person in Germany.
What does this private
balance sheet consist of?
On the asset side of the balance sheet,
you can distinguish tangible assets
from the financial assets.
Typical tangible assets
would be Real Estate
so all the houses or apartments
that you might own as a private person.
Also, if you're the direct owner
of a commercial enterprise,
then the net value of the enterprise,
you can also consider a tangible asset.
In addition to that, it can
be all kinds of other things
of tangible value that you own.
For instance, jewellery,
vehicles, art collections
or anything similar to that.
Looking at the financial assets,
private persons can have a
checking or a savings account,
so pretty much the money
that you have in the bank.
Then you can have stocks,
bonds, derivatives,
or other financial products like that.
And especially in Germany,
many people have a balance
from a pension or life insurance.
That of course has a significant
intrinsic value as well.
And especially in Germany,
many people have a balance
from a pension or life insurance,
which can of course hold a
significant intrinsic value
as well.
And of course there can be all kinds
of other financial holdings
that people might own.
They can be subsumed under the
term of financial assets.
What are typical
liabilities that people hold
on a personal level?
One of the most common one are mortgages.
So if you buy a home and
you get a loan from that
from the bank, and then
you have a mortgage
on that house, there
will be a mortgage credit
that would be liability.
What unfortunately also many
people have is consumer credit.
So this will be open
balances on your credit card
or other lines of credits that you use
to finance consumer spending.
So if you buy a television at the store
and you agree to not pay it right now,
but at some point later in the future,
this would be an example
of consumer credit.
Another category would be student loans.
So if you incur debt
to study at university
and finally business credits,
so if you take a credit
on your personal name
and all to finance some kind
of commercial business
operation that you are running.
And this is now how you can calculate
your personal net worth.
So if you sum up the
value of all your assets
and you deduct all your liabilities,
then the result of that is the net worth.
So to put a more
intuitive meaning to that,
the net worth is the value
of the funds available to you
in the longterm to finance
your private investing
and spending activities.
So your net worth can be negative
if the liabilities exceed your assets,
you have a negative net worth.
But of course what you want to aim for is
to have a high positive net worth.
So to own assets that
significantly exceed the value
of all the liabilities that you have.
Why do so many young
professionals struggle
to increase the net worth?
And at least from my observations,
the typical career path
of a young professional is
that he spent several years at university.
During university many of
these people had a rather
frugal lifestyle.
They lived in rather small shared flats,
they weren't able to
afford too many luxuries
and then suddenly after
university they get the first job,
maybe it's already the
second or the third job,
and they realize that now
they have a significant income
at their disposal.
At least the income is much
more significant than it was
when they were a university student.
And they realize that
with this higher income,
their financial means
increased significantly
and they start to improve the lifestyle.
They start to move into a larger flat,
they start to get a nicer vehicle.
They get some nice cloth,
some other luxury equipment
an expensive laptop.
So they increase their
spending just to the level
that they can afford with
their current salary.
So what happens if they get a promotion
and earn even more money,
where then this offer means
to getting even a larger flat,
even a larger car, even
more expensive cloth
and so on and so on.
This pattern of behavior is
called lifestyle inflation.
And this leads to a phenomenon
that is called high-income low net worth.
Even if you're in the top 10%
or maybe even top 1% of
income earners in your country,
if you spend it all, if
you do not save anything
and the only thing you
buy are consumer goods,
then you will barely build
any net worth at all.
So this can make you end up in a situation
that even though you
earn significant amounts
of money year after year,
your net worth is barely larger than zero
because you didn't save anything
and you did not do any investment.
So let's assume now that so
far we are on the same page.
Either I convinced you now
or maybe you already had the attitude
that yes, you need to
save a certain amount
of your income and you need to invest it.
But now you might ask yourself, Heinrich,
how should I invest my money?
I mean currently the interest
rates are pretty much zero,
if I just leave my money
on my account in the bank,
the inflation rate, just eat it up.
What shall I do with my money?
Let's start by looking into
what the average person
is actually doing with this money.
And in this video I'm going to
especially reference numbers
and statistics from Germany.
So apologies of this might be
a bit less interesting to you
if you're not a German
or not living in Germany,
but I'm sure that the
conclusions that are drawn
from the numbers are
applicable independent
from where you live.
So as you can see here,
Germans hold the vast majority
of their assets in cash or bank deposits,
so they just leave it on the bank,
they just save in as your grandma did,
they just prefer to have
it under their pillow.
Then closely after that, are insurances,
and this is again a very German thing,
Germans like to buy pension insurances
or life insurances and they
invest a significant amount
of money in these insurance plans.
In this video, I'm not going
to talk about insurances too much,
I just want to mention the main downside
of many of these insurance plans
and this is that they cost a lot of money.
The insurance provider would take away
significant amount of all the money
that you pay in as costs
for its own operations.
So very frequently the
payoffs that you get
from these insurance plans
are not really worth the investment.
And of course this is
now a generous statement
and you would need to look
into the individual plans
to understand whether
it makes sense or not.
The next asset class is
stocks or funds of stocks,
and this is where really
wanna put your attention on
because stocks play only a minor role
in the asset allocation of the
average John Doe in Germany.
And you might tell yourself, no way,
of course stocks are risky,
who buys stocks anyway,
but what is especially
interesting in my perspective is
that Germany here really
has a special role compared
to other countries.
These numbers are from a report of 2018
and they show the share of the population
that is holding stocks.
And you see that why in Germany only 6%
of the population is holding stocks.
In our neighbor country, France 15%
of the population is owning stocks,
in the US, 25% of the
population is owning stocks
and in the Netherlands 30%
of the population is owning stocks.
And this is really
interesting and surprising.
And also in Academia,
there's lots of research
in the personal finance field
looking at these questions,
why are only so few Germans
investing in the stock market?
While all kinds of
reasons are hypothesized,
the result is clear
and this is that the Germans
lose a significant opportunity
for wealth creation because only so few
of them actually invest
in the stock market.
But probably a significant share
of you already understood this
because yesterday I did a little survey
on my Instagram Channel
@firmlearning and I asked who
of you already invest in stock regularly?
And I was happy to see
that a significant portion
of you is actually are
already investing regularly
in stocks.
So very glad that here at Firm Learning
we already have a pretty
financially savvy community.
And the reason for that is that stocks,
at least in the longterm,
almost always outperform other
asset classes.
Here is your comparison
of annualized results
of different asset classes
over the last 15 years
and you see that Large Cap Stocks,
so stocks of large companies have achieved
annualized returns of
~8% so they're increasing
by ~8% every year on average.
And yes, while it is
true that the volatility,
so the risk of this
investment is quite high
so if you look at it month after month
or year after year there
can be quite significant
fluctuations and there also
can be significant losses
as we also see right now at the moment
in the current financial crisis
if your stocks in the long term,
at least when you look at the past,
you are always on the
winning side in the variant.
In the personal finance literature,
there's a broad consensus that investing
in stocks is a good financial
decision for most people.
So this would be my
first key recommendation.
If you're a young professional
and you are able to save a
bit of money to the side,
start investing in the stock market
and in a few moments I'm going to show you
what I exactly bought, how I got started,
what I believed at the time
from doing the research,
what the good first investments
in the stock market would be.
But before I get there, I
just want to stress the point
that I believe that it is
really crucial to start early.
This is another point that I
frequently hear from talking
to friends and other peers
and this is the day say,
well, I'm in my late twenties
I'm in my early thirties,
I'm just so young, I just do
not need to save money yet.
Right now I want to enjoy life.
I want to get the best life possible
and the maybe later some
years down the line,
I'm going to start saving
and to think about my future.
And from my opinion at least if you want
to optimize your net worth,
this is a significant mistake.
These people tend to
significantly underestimate
how money can compound over
time and the advantages
that you have if you
start investing early.
And here's let's have a simple chart
that I found online
that compares two types
of investment strategies.
The one guy on the left starts
to invest $2,000 every
year, starting when he's 19
until when he is 26
and will not invest any
more money afterwards.
The guy on the right is not
investing any money at all
when he's young, but only starts
investing €2000 every year
from the year of 27.
And if you compare now the value
of their holdings at the age of 65,
you see that the left guy has
a significant higher value
in his holding than the guy on the right,
even though he put into
significantly less money
than the person on the right.
And in this calculation
exercise, they calculated
with 10% return year on year.
So you could argue non
that 10% in the longterm
are a bit too high of a return rate.
And of course, if you
calculate with a lower rate
of return then the differences
between these two
examples really diminish,
but I hope that you get the point
that starting early is extremely important
and can deliver significant
amounts of value to you
and to your net worth.
So what can you do now to get started?
And one thing that I know
many people are afraid of
is the pressure to needing
to select the right stocks.
How do you know what stocks will increase
in value over time?
And the good message that I have
for you here is that it's much easier.
It's not about picking the
one, two, or three top stocks,
but you can go broad.
And the main reason for that is the effect
of diversification.
So when you look at risk,
you can often distinguish
the systematic risk
from the unsystematic risk.
So the systematic risk is the
risk that affects all stocks
at the same time.
So it's something like the
current health situation
affecting pretty much
all stocks out there,
it is not a risk that is
immanent on a specific stock.
Different from that, is
the unsystematic risk.
And this is the risk that is
immanent in a specific company.
So it's a risk that only
this one company is facing.
For instance, the risk
that a specific plant
of a company needs to shut
down due to an emergency event
and then the company
cannot produce anymore.
And this risk can be
reduced by diversifying.
So by owning several of
these stocks, not only one.
And as you can see here in the chart,
the more stocks you own, the
lower this unsystematic risk
that you hold.
But of course at some point
there is a diminishing effect,
so after certain number of stocks,
the risk goes only down
by a marginal amount
for the next best stock that you buy.
Most people see this inflection point
from where then the additional benefit
of further stocks reduces more
and more to be around 20 stocks.
So this means that we should
own at least 20 stocks
in our portfolio to get the
effect of diversification.
So what is the portfolio of
stocks that you should buy?
And financial theory tells us
that we should own the market portfolio,
but what is the market portfolio?
The definition of a market portfolio is
"a portfolio consisting of the
weighted sum of every asset
in the market with
weights in the proportion
that they exist in the market".
So the market portfolio means
to pretty much own every asset
that exists out there in the market.
So the reason why you should
own the market portfolio
compared to any other portfolio out there,
probably is material enough
for a whole other video.
So please just let us
assume here that it is right
that you want to own the market portfolio.
So you might ask yourself
now, well, how do I do that?
Because obviously I cannot
buy every single stock
that exists out there.
I cannot own every single
asset that exists in the world.
And because this is true, we need a proxy
for the market portfolio.
Something that comes close
enough to the market portfolio
and that is set up in a way
that we can easily invest in it.
And typically you do that by investing
in so-called exchange-traded funds (ETFs).
So in a simplified way, these are baskets
of all kinds of stocks that
they put together according
to certain criteria to
enable you to easily invest
in such a market portfolio.
And if you ask yourself now, Heinrich,
there are so many funds out there,
which specific funds shall I buy?
Then if you look into the
personal finance literature,
while there are of course many,
many different options
of combinations of funds you could buy
to build such a market portfolio,
the most easiest combination
that comes close enough,
if you just want something
easy to get you started,
it would be a combination
of 70% of the portfolio
in the MSCI World and 30% of
the MSCI Emerging Markets.
So the MSCI World and
the MSCI Emerging Markets
are two indices that are
brought out by the company MSCI.
There are lots of ETFs that try
to replicate the performance
of these indices that you can
buy in order to participate
from the development of this
index for your own portfolio.
So what are these two indices composed of?
So let's start with the
first with the MSCI World.
And the MSCI World tries to
give you a good combination
of large companies in developed countries.
The top 10 companies that are represented
in this index are Microsoft,
Apple, Amazon, Facebook,
two types of Alphabet, meaning
Google, Johnson &Johnson,
Nestle, JPMorgan Chase, and Visa.
In total, these 10
companies make about 15%
of the total holdings.
You can see that there are
many, many more companies
that the MSCI Word has
represented in his index.
If you now look into the country split,
the five most commonly
represented countries are the US
with 64%, Japan with 9%, the
UK with 5%, France with 4%,
Switzerland with 3% and roughly 15%
of other countries in it.
Let's now compare this to the
MSCI Emerging Markets index,
which tries to give you a combination
of larger companies of countries
which are still in the growth phase.
And the top 10 companies represented
in the MSCI Emerging market
index is first Alibaba,
then Tencent, Taiwan
Semiconductors, Samsung Electronics,
China Construction,
Naspers, Ping An Insurance,
China Mobile, ICBC and Reliance Industries.
And together these top
10 companies make up 28%
of the total index.
So you can see that here as well,
there are many other
companies represented.
And as well let's look
into the top five represented countries.
Largest one is China with 41%
followed by Taiwan with 12%,
South Korea with 12%, India
with 8%, Brazil with 5%
and then 23% with other countries.
So here you have it guys,
if you want to build a simple version
of a market portfolio, invest with 70%
of your funds into the MSCI World index
and with 30% of your funds
into the MSCI Emerging Markets index.
And if you ask yourself what
specific ETFs you should buy,
if you just google ETF MSCI World
or ETF MSCI Emerging
Markets, you will find lots
of comparisons of all the
different ETFs out there.
And trust you can come to
your own conclusions here,
which specific product you want to buy.
And again, of course it can
get much more sophisticated,
you can buy all kinds of
other combinations of assets
and of course you need to
realize that with this version
of the market portfolio,
you only invest in stocks.
So maybe at some point you
might also ask yourself
to add some bonds or
some other asset classes,
but if you just want to get
started investing your money,
so for myself, I concluded
this would be a good
and great start to get
my investing started
and now reflecting on that, looking back,
I at least the believe that
this is the right way to go
for at least most young
professionals out there.
So again, I'm not a finance professional,
I do not want to give
you investment advice.
All of those are just my
personal private experiences
and reflections on how
to handle your money
as a young professional.
But I'd love to hear from you
now, what is your perspective?
Do you save, do you invest in stocks?
How do you handle your finances
as young professionals?
Let me know in the comments below,
I'm happy to answer all your questions
and just get into a discussion with you
on what you are doing with your finances.
If you took any value out
of this video at all
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to this
channel for more content
on how to be successful in the
first years of your career.
And if you'd like to
see even more from me,
follow me on my Instagram @firmlearning
where I post daily
content updates for you.
As always doing this video
was a pleasure for me.
Thank you for watching
and have a great day.